this movie exists I have to say these
are pretty goddamn awesome opening
credits it's even got Karen oh and Trent
Reznor doing a fing Led Zeppelin cover
but it also takes forever so I'm sending
the self-indulgence even while I'm
popping my head to the sick beat what is
this nudie event of the year just go
ahead and establish that preposterous
Lee all characters speak English in a
predominantly non-english speaking
country during an American film
everyone's believed properly suspended
like their movie if you're gonna give us
News position please focus on one
broadcast so we can figure out what the
hell's going on
granted I don't know what cafes are like
in Stockholm but I have my doubts that
people would come and grab coffee and
pastries at a place that has TVs with
jacked up volume on at all times
oh cool nico works at that short-lived
nineties fox show that starlets
Henriksen poor gregor the book at least
gives a little background on the fact
that he doesn't really care about
Michael and Erica sleeping together but
in the movie he just comes across as
pure cock I need to know if this
anything about him I might find unsavory
why Frodo wants to hire Miko because of
his great investigative work and given
the nature of the hush-hush operation
Michaels private life shouldn't even
factor into this I think throat is
really just waiting for the part about
the cunnilingus
sometimes he performs cunnilingus not
often enough in my opinion they never
really actually explicate who they're
talking about during the scene but based
on this exchange you could be damn sure
it's not DJ Khaled or someone who made
it very clear earlier she only does what
she's asked to do this bouncer is doing
a lot of things she wasn't asked to do
are you giving up Stefan is fine
this makes me sick what makes me sick is
the fact that the movie chose to include
all this minutiae about the fall of
blumquist career in addition to
Lisbeth's horrible background and
subsequent revenge the mystery not
mystery of Harriet's disappearance the
Nazi Martin's killin boner Lisbeth
brilliance at packing but social
anxieties the developing relationship
between her and Michael and let's see
what am I leave me out oh yeah Gregor
okay movie spent the last 30 seconds of
silent driving and Michael's stunt
expression to build us up to bangers
opulence and sure it's a nice big house
and all but it ain't the King Taj Mahal
so what do you know about me I remove
all the sins for this movie if Miko
asked him if Kevin Spacey previously
played this role would you like to see
if I could possibly replace if necessary
man you'd think with a strong beautiful
central character that was also a hacker
this movie would avoid the stereotype of
other hackers being fat lazy dudes but
you'd be wrong this is it maybe a
picture from the past but this scene is
total fiord shadowing Suites position
someone in the family murdered Harriet
and for the past 40 years that's been
trying to drive me insane so is there
something about the 40th anniversary
that caused Henrik to call me I know it
was convenient that he just had all that
legal business and was available but
there have to be hundreds of people in
Sweden or elsewhere that could do an
excellent job just as discreetly some
even make careers out of it like the
person you hired to investigate Michael
also since we eventually find out
Harriet has been sending the gifts for
the past 40 years you have to wonder why
is she doing that it's definitely not
the East End Rick's mind considering he
definitely thinks she's dead she wasn't
dead the next morning or the next the
next 40 years this is a compelling
mystery no doubt and it's got a pretty
interesting resolution but it also takes
up an absurd amount of time in a story
that's ultimately about Michael's
Redemption and Lisbeth badassery I mean
it's over two and a half hours that's
transformers length I need you here not
the North Pole Miko you know what this
is going to look like look kudos to
Robin right and a few others for giving
the Swedish accent the old college try
but the ultimate lack of authenticity is
one of the many reasons that most people
prefer to watch the original Swedish
version to this one they should have
just gone the Star Wars route and made
everyone speak British
[Music]
hey you buddy that was Kurt Vonnegut's
last book quickly losing track of who's
who here
Nikhil speaks for the audience and movie
immediately raises two giant middle
fingers in response hot researching
action no one will be seated during the
scenes of Michael highlighting police
reports also is he seriously
highlighting everything on the page
except no sign of breakin seems like
that's a pretty important point or at
least as highlight or worthy as the rest
of the pages why are there so many
busted ass sheds on this island banger
and his family are the only inhabitants
and he has all the money in the world so
why haven't they clean there's the fact
that I never found a body was not
surprising you can't dig up an entire
aisle okay I mean if you're doing a full
investigation and you think there's been
foul play wouldn't you do whatever you
needed to do to solve the case the
islands not that big but neither could I
find a motive and we caught me and many
others he could easily see her running
the company one day sounds exactly like
a motive would you institutionalisation
skip no seriously can we skip over all
of this I guess it's important to the
story but Jesus just let us skip jeez
what a creepy smile if I met this dude
I'd immediately be on my skarsgård I'm
afraid I'm a little out of shape this is
clearly the in-between Bond films Daniel
Craig what a place about view I mean
we've been shown almost the entirety of
the island already and besides the
houses there ain't much to look at
especially in the dead of night
that's why she'd never marry me that's
one reason I guess proud infidelity is a
thing in Sweden I thought I'd come over
and say hello I'm so seeing you oh yes
Michael's been studying the crap out of
this family putting up photographs and
on his crazy homeland map of suspects
and even if he didn't have a recent
photo how would he not recognize someone
vital to the case and one that lives all
in the island I wonder sometimes who's
crazier my naazy father or my obsessed
uncles but not see it's definitely the
Nazi I'm writing a biography of your
Uncle Henry that's that's why I'm damn
fine all the way to London to drop in
unannounced to and heat his place of
business only to broadside her with this
is like the definition of gotcha
journalism
come on I know I'm skipping a decent
chunk of this movie because while it's
probably in a central plot point to the
overall narrative
unlike the fucking Harriet Bulls the
movie there's a little too much on the
stuff between Lisbeth and Biermann
especially before Lisbeth gets her
revenge and even though that revenge is
looking sweet
it's a rough go getting their lease for
a movie anyway just trust me then I sat
through a lot of unnecessary ickiness
and we're just gonna give it five sins
and move on
[Music]
and I'm glad I got to see yet another
scene of Michael researching some about
Harriet looking confused and then
putting that information down and moving
on to something else did I actually get
the super extended director's cut of
this no god damn it
there's no vomit inside Claire
Underwood's in cars getting colder
without their money we'll be out of
business in three you don't know this
family like I do that that crazy first
off welcome to the J story of this movie
which involves the financial
independence of the magazine that
Michael most recently worked for you
know what David
not everything from the book needed to
go into the movie also the is Michael
talking about Jer there's some awful
people tangentially in this family but
so far as he knows the business is run
by Martin and Henrik who are trustworthy
and the company's been enormous ly
successful so it makes all the sense in
the world to partner with them just
because he played Bond doesn't mean you
have to have a beautiful woman disrobing
in silhouette movie are you referring to
mr. Bannister I'm referring to anyone
who tries to sue his enemies into
submission a vendor store in a movie
where every character is sadistic
unlikable or disagreeable at best at
least we can take solace in the fact
that everyone hates you who since this
sensitive boneheaded sentiment as a
fucking email and even if he needed to
send it look how many assholes he copied
movie crime solver discovers important
clue from accidentally dropping papers
on the floor cliche
despite someone taking the time to zoom
in on the picture of the girl in the
window and the original investigation no
one mentions this it determines the
position of Michael's glasses when he's
looking at something close-up sometimes
they're hanging from his chin
haphazardly or he'll just take them off
completely and sometimes they're up on
his head is the next stop to turn them
around on the back of his head like guy
Yeti yeah and yes she does even more
satisfying to this asshole
but this is a family channel and we can
only show you so much but yeah one
problem in adapting mystery novels to
film is that the investigative scenes
are not always the most cinematic The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo is not the
exception
Jesus Lizbeth Tyler Durden much hi hi oh
hi daughter of our protagonist that
totally doesn't need to exist and that
will only see for about five seconds in
this movie I'm not writing an article
about this mEagle actually a good
investigator or does he just gets super
lucky like Harry Potter lucky based on
what's been presented so far I leaned
toward the ladder so it was movie
telling me that Swedish phone numbers
and Bible chapter and verse code
breakers are the exact same length
because I think I'm calling bolt on at
least one of those things I have one of
those sandwich
smell scotch you see if wrote it when
you mess around with the pronoun game
you could end up getting a liverwurst
sandwich instead of that sweet Biddy
goodness she's a ward of the state she's
had a rough life this comes after
Michaels is prodded and threatened
Dragan during this conversation so let
me have just told him he needed a
research assistant I want to tell you a
story and if it entertains you maybe
you'll decide to help me research
further this is a bold strategy because
the Harriet story is hugely
unentertaining Elizabeth I want you to
help me catch a killer of women movie
takes an hour and 19 minutes to properly
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo absolutely
no idea to the rest of these people
though and I also have no idea what
happened to whatever accent I was using
at the beginning of this movie so let's
just pretend I'm British and go with
that yet why would a young lady like you
want to know about such an awful murder
it interests me wait another murder
mystery plot inside a murder mystery
plot that's like 16 murder mystery plots
we moved on to a neighbor and a vagrant
once you get two strangers it's only a
matter of time before you get the
gypsies and you know you're never going
to solve it all those unsolved murders
in Sweden because no one can get the
gypsies to talk in gypsies need surgery
but there's no death on in place so it's
up to the family to decide a should the
occasion arise whether to resuscitate or
not I don't know how medicine works in
Sweden but if there's no DNR in place
doesn't that mean the doctors you know
hafta or you must stay the last chance
Henrik has of some kind of resolution
granted this paints Martin as a good guy
and not a murderer but since we
eventually find out he is this scene
makes zero sense
why would Martin want Michael who he
knows is a good investigator to continue
to dig up history that could eventually
expose him the killer encased the
animals who smashed the aquarium's
there was a parakeet inside her oddly
enough she actually died of the bird flu
tyrunt's nemesis
and walk yes Dan can anyone speak in
full sentences in this movie it's always
a fragment of a thought prompting the
other person to ask what the end part of
the sentence is you know what that makes
me what angry don't give you any of this
stuff without authorization from mr. or
mom school so call him what was the
point of that scene it's not what dude
is intimidated nor is Lizabeth it like
this that bloats the runtime of an
otherwise decent movie and I'm perplexed
why David Fincher didn't edit his like
he normally does we find Clint was over
two and a half hours also and gone girl
and zodiac was nearly three hours what
the Fincher Oh what the hell he had to
go into the whole shower
I couldn't just wash his face over the
sink you're going to go to an actual
doctor to have that looked at right yeah
the sex I mean the research is going
really great not wondering if you could
do that I don't speak to him yes you
know you're in the same room with him
man this island is 80% made up of people
who don't speak to each other I know it
was played for a joke earlier but
seriously if it's this bad I don't at
least some of the move your interest is
in my more candid photographic voice if
you mean non racist piece of photos then
yes if Lizbeth has a photographic memory
why'd she have to lay on all the
pictures of the girls on the map is it
really for her or for us oh man turns
out Michael was looking for Pennywise
this whole time guess he's gonna be
hightailing it to the old well house
okay the movies established that Godfrey
killed and tortured these girls based on
passages from the Old Testament and that
he was training Martin to do the same
and the question marks here denote that
someone other than Godfrey
Martin committed the last known what but
when Martin tells me Cole all that he's
done since there's no mention of
religious motivation at all if he
carried on his father's work with poor
Lena Andersson why'd he stop Leviticus
Inc I'm just saying you've got a clear
motivation movie stick with that I know
this is an island and everything but
this is a very expensive house you're
telling me Martin didn't have any home
security alarms or even locks on the
door come on in
I'll make a drink this movie is so gross
that I can't even make a Bill Cosby joke
here in good conscience although I guess
I should never make a Bill Cosby joke
so for making me have that responsible
yet crushing realization this movie gets
a sick
so in 40 years not one person that
investigated this case figured out that
Martin was in this photograph the
balloon partially hides his face but
with all the questioning on this case
over the years someone should have
uncovered this piece of info before now
no it's harder the shooting
just missing it goddamn it wait until
you're down in the torture chamber
before you start your villainy
exposition Martin
let's ain't your first rodeo act like
you've been here before well that's a
massively inefficient way to knock your
subject out what happened a good
old-fashioned chloroform and work just
fine for the Horde also he could have at
least had Michaels set to drink down or
taking it from him before setting off
the gas just giving himself unnecessary
clean up in his torture porn ventures
did your drink because Michaels supposed
to drink that even homicidal lunatics
don't waste good scotch
Eli Lapp talking there's another coffee
on our website this is what gives Martin
this much confidence I know he's doing
his creepy omniscient villain Act here
and there's a good chance that Michael
is locked why would he even leave that
to chance yeah pretty crazy that you
both came to the same realization almost
at the exact same time that would have
been so disappointing for both of you
when you're about to drop this knowledge
bomb and both of you know what the other
is gonna say so and there's no way you
would make it out of this situation
alive so I'm going to give you this
honest and forthcoming interview about
crimes that I've covered up for decades
also is it just me or is the scene a
little too Casino Royale
although something's missing oh yeah we
need Miko to get naked you knew
something was wrong she came back into
the house but Michael had no clue that
Martin knew anything was amiss sure it
would have been better for him to walk a
white bud he was potentially gonna get
even more information and really nothing
would have been different if Martin
hadn't noticed the knife missing I
realized this is just a crazy old loot
doing some amateur philosophy but he
makes it sound like what Michael did was
entirely stupid and it wasn't damn it
well I see the Hope trainee from their
face like it is from yours right now
I can feel myself getting hard part of
me wants to take a sin off for stellan
skarsgård delivering that line so
convincing me and part of me wants just
a q-tip so far down my eardrums that I
will never have to hear dialogue like
that
utter it again so we're not that
different you and I cliche that's racist
you know I'm gonna send the fact that
Martin left it unlocked and that Lisbeth
knew exactly where the hidden torture
chamber is and came prepared to take out
the dude that's currently torturing but
honestly I'm too disappointed and how
rote and boring the end of the plot is
just dig it and we'll carry on the girl
with the Callaway 5-iron
there's a gun and even though Martin had
both of us dead to rights the only
people that know about his crimes he ran
off like a little biatch instead of
using that gun on us my father no no see
that's a much more interesting story
that we could have seen instead you had
to over blow this first entry and scare
everyone off from doing the other two
movies in the trilogy forcing us to sit
through a fucking half-baked spiderweb
pseudo sequel in seven years
sure she's doing something but that's
not really solitaire could be one of
those weird-ass spider or beast Haven or
golf or Josephine or Klondike knockoffs
but that is not real solitaire before he
died your brother away from her and this
works so how did you escape
anytime cool cool by my count we're
wrapping up the 18th storyline so that's
good progress only twenty three more to
go the coldest part of the court of
public opinion
now celebrates people's bad behavior
well get your 2016 politics out of my
2011 neo-punk hacker thriller what
happened to it Spanish him how did he
get you why is Lizabeth asking this now
or at all she wrote the book on this guy
literally I had access to his computer
and his accountant and his lawyers and
how do you have that well I could have
gotten it from my sources either come
back yeah but this will definitely put
him back in court charges will be filed
and Michael will be a very unreliable
witness when any of this is found out to
be bullshit I mean isn't Michael doing
the exact thing that got him in trouble
the first time but this time it's gonna
work out because Lisbeth the country and
this Venice Trump's top plot takes up a
lot at the end of this movie especially
for previously having been yada-yada for
the vast majority of it Jesus this movie
has more innings than Return of the King
how
any of these would you like to convert
for deposit or fifty into five accounts
wait so Lisbeth took fifty thousand
dollars of Michaels money then stole all
of Venice crumbs money went to a couple
of Gringotts branches move some around
ended up making billions does something
with it then has him killed
do I have that tiny little bow on this
unnecessary plot point right yeah what
is up with that though I know Michaels
all free lovey and all that but couldn't
you at least have given Lisbeth the
heads-up on what was going on with him
and Erica and how would Gregor even feel
about this considering his wife is fing
a guy that's working another girl who's
doing a lot of random people this is
Harry Harry it's part hearted harbinger
of haggis this is so badly the time
taken we got away from you at the worst
possible time badly is an adverb so to
say you feel badly would be saying that
the mechanism which allows you to feel
is broken through the all-singing
all-dancing crap of the world the Dread
Pirate Roberts visit with fried that was
doing advanced mathematical when I was
when I was 18 and it still took me over
20 years to do something worthy of a
Fields map there's more to life than a
Fields Medal it's not a snuff it's a
wide-angle fiber optics lab the price is
wrong bitch